bailleul ancien cadet âgées time's up
qui est qui houba l'américaine il vaut
mieux avoir plus d'un jeu dans son sac
pour occuper les enfants
si ces séances ressemble un peu une
récréation ces adolescents sont bien en
plein apprentissage
c'est le premier stage du cycle de
formation au bafa et il consiste en la
découverte des fonctions de l'animateur
qui sont donc abordé à travers des temps
de réflexion et des temps d'animation
sur l'ut jour on privilégie plutôt des
temps de réflexion qui leur permettent
de découvrir pas quels sont les
différents besoins des enfants selon les
tranches d'âge
comment s'organiser comme on gère la vie
quotidienne bien expliquer les règles
encadrent et être attentif aux
difficultés autant d'éléments à prendre
en compte pour devenir animateur une
quinzaine de jeunes se prête à
l'exercice avec plus ou moins
d'expérience j'ai fait beaucoup de colo
et d'accueil de loisirs quand j'étais
plus petit et j'aimais bien
j'aimais bien les animateurs je trouvais
ça marrant et je sais pas ça m'a
toujours attiré 2 d'animer des enfants
de jouer avec eux qu'est-ce qui est
difficile de savoir expliquer par
exemple des animations trouvé le temps
de les faire et à notre âge c'est un peu
compliqué et ce qui est facile c'est
qu'on soit quand appartement on a les
pieds à des petites soeurs on s'est un
peu comment s'en occuper j'ai plutôt
voulu participer parce que j'ai entraîne
au foot et du coup sa mort sam apprenez
à développer mes connaissances sur les
enfants quoi seule condition pour passer
son bafa être âgé au minimum de 17 ans
une première étape quasiment validé pour
ses candidats
les futurs animateurs auront encore deux
stages à passer avant d'obtenir leur
brevet